tout d'abord je dois dire que moi j'ai
pas de playback
moi je plais où j'ai plaît pas et pis
c'est tout mais bon et comme m'a dit
michel briquet dans notre émission vous
pouvez prendre tous les risques mais
choisit c'est quand même la sécurité
alors je me mouille pas j'ai choisi la
sécurité
qu'est ce qui me gêne aussi les clés de
ma loge
j'appelle ça des clés dans une borne
kilométrique à défaut donc dernièrement
j'ai vu une émission à la télévision qui
m'a beaucoup intéressé c'était l'année
dernière
sir la vie des mozart et ça m'a donné
l'envi de lire sa biographie
c'est comme ça que je me suis aperçu que
nous avons des points communs avec
mozart par exemple consomme biologiste
écrit kelly moore est rare chez les
génies ma modestie m'oblige à penser que
je n'ai donc pas d'humour
ou alors que je suis un des rares à
avoir les deux et comme électrique et
mozart avait le 2 c'est un premier point
commun
deuxième point commun à quatre ans
mozart composaient son premier livre est
et moi aussi à 4 ans j'ouvrais mon
premier livre est à la caisse d'epargne
troisième point commun avec moïse avec
et mozart parce qu'avec moi il aussi je
n'ai point commun
quand il est monté sur le mont sinaï
année 3000 avant jc
pour aller chercher les dix
commandements il est resté là au 40
jours après le dixième boyz ii men c'est
tout et l'éternel répondre en déjà ça si
ça se vende bien j'en écrirai d'autres
mais la différence avec moïse c'est
celui recevez la parole divine
il avait quatre ans m tandis que moi
j'écris la parole elle est peut-être pas
divine mais divine et combien gagnent à
être connus donc troisième point commun
avec mozart mozart à 25 ans était au
sommet de son génie et c'est là que nos
chemins divergent
parce que moi à 25 ans je dois
reconnaître que la source volcanique qui
donne des sous les sommets de la calotte
crânienne ne trouvait pas la sortie
j reconnaît humblement que je suis resté
longtemps en bouche et je trouvais pas
de débouchés
bien joué ou plutôt une nuit comme
beethoven qu'il a entendu pompon peau
j'ai entendu popeck je me suis dit c'est
un signe et j'ai ouvert les yeux et
c'est là que je les appelais sion j'ai
vu la vierge comme j'aime boire je me
suis dit c'est pas possible c'est trompé
d'appartement ou son mari vous c'est
pour ça que je n'ai jamais dit à
personne je savais qu'on me croirait pas
et elle m'a parlé
elle m'a dit papeete le monde est triste
fais moi rire que lui dis avec quoi
señorita moi c'est la mère du seigneur
bon à l'enseigné rita
et elle m'a tendu un stylo un diplôme
hors garantie 3 ans elle m'a dit écrit
et la disparue sans jamais réparé et
pourtant je les appelais plusieurs fois
mais faudrait des riches pour les stylos
et alors dernier point avec coo et
mozart qui a écrit une sonate en
aluminium en élite et mimi nerfs
intitulé les marchés aux tic et mois
parallèlement à sa musique j'ai écrit
une sonate en un poème en vrac intitulé
les marchés aux tic
si vous voulez je peux vous enchanter un
morceau il m'aurait fallu un pianiste
pour m'accompagner - vous savez j'ai
demandé au conservatoire j'ai demandé un
bon pianiste ils m'ont proposé un
premier prix alors je leur ai dit au
dernier prix c'est combien cod pris un
pianiste avait rien de méchant tu es
tout seul je vais vous chanter la vie de
maurice chez mon ami le vieux machos les
caleçons molletonnés qui va des villes
en villages si la place et des marchés
près de lui il ya les bouquinistes et la
mercière et les veaux boucher et la
jolie petite grévistes et à l'accent des
méditerranée et je vois encore ces
baratineurs mais on a monté à démonter à
des vallées savoie comines et qui
laissait les vous fendez lequel approché
tout chez moi ça ce n'est pas de la
gnognotte et approcher choisissez cg
c'est l'adopter c'est quand il fait pour
qu'on se sent bien dans les tissus que
la firme ne vous piquez pas les guides
cetera et cetera
j'ai l'adriq et où les jolies piano
c'est pour moi qui voulais amener celui
là ohlala les touches sont toutes noires
dit dont il a besoin d'aller chez le
dentiste heures
oui pour faire un détartrage mathias
avait donné l'idée si j'ai encore une
minute géant boeing
je vais vous jouez là je vais vous la
jouer à les marchés aux tic à l'aris
seulement je dois vous prévenir que si
vous entendez des fausses notes ne les
croyez pas à céret de la propagande anti
soviétique
je vous demande juste une minute les
temps de faire la mise au point avec mes
musiciens
alors écoutez moi bien vous êtes dix
doigts il ya 85 note
il y en aura pour tout le monde
alors venez vous montez par les anciens
les autres
comment s'est allégé tôt et finissent et
très tôt et c'est là que vous allez voir
que nos points communs serré joint avec
mozart parce que si c'est vrai que la
musique adoucit les makes les ti ci
aussi à doucier les makes parce que
mozart vous réchauffe l'homme pour la
musique mais moi j'ai vous réchauffer
qui pariait dans le temps
ah bon
à